vous l'avez été oui dans tout le monde
tout le monde dans ce métier c'est un
peux pas accepter ça non pas comme tout
le monde dans ce métier comme peut-être
ceux qui sortent la nuit tous les atouts
les bains bref tout c'est un passage
obligé sur la vous vous trompez on peut
demander à plein des gens aussi sur ce
plateau je pense pas qu'on soit tous
drogués sinon j'aime bien tout le monde
d'accord comme tous les gens qui
critiquent que je fréquentais tout les
hélices et ceux qui sortaient la nuit
quand on est jeune on sent la nuit un ou
alors j'ai pas dû être jeu de jambes
j'étais milieu de tout cela
ophélie winter donc c'est vrai que cette
sortie elle est follement hawking à
lucid
moi j'aimerais qu'on soit sans langue de
bois ce soir il est batteur 13 on en
direct c'est vrai que benjamin castaldi
la drogue dans le show business et tel
tabou vous donnons nord quoi vous dit
non parce que on en parle beaucoup mais
on fait beaucoup de fantasmes sur ça
c'est vrai que ce que dit laurent
ruquier il dit c'est pas tout le monde
savait que le monde de la nuit oui si on
sort beaucoup il est des gens sont à
remplir le monde de la nuit passée les
boîtes de nuit ces débats on connaît
voilà où on croise beaucoup de gens et
c'est vrai que malgré le couvre-feu donc
web apps et voilà ça devient beaucoup
plus compliqué mais on est bon c'est
vrai et c'est vrai que c'est un fantasme
ont du chien aussi voyant des médecins
qui est très en forme là bas tient lui
voilà il prend la drogue du tabac non
mais non mais non
alors côté pas sur moi pour balancer des
noms bien sûr mais mais mais je trouve
quelque chose c'est que j'ai croisé
beaucoup plus d'avocats d'hommes
d'affaires qui faisait la fête et qui
consommait des drogues que d'animateur
télé par exemple pour être tout à fait
honnête le mythe le mythe de dire dans
le showbiz sont tous cas mais c'est un
raccourci qui pour moi est totalement
faux après malheureusement c'est vrai
que moi j'ai des copains qui qui qui qui
qui sont laissés 30 par la chose moi
j'aurais alors je bernard montiel
valérie bénaïm moi j'ai ma qualité vous
avez des carrières et non est-ce que
vous avez déjà toucher à ça bernard
montiel sincèrement jamais jamais j'ai
trop peur de perdre le contrôle donc je
sens
oui c'était un truc qui m'a toujours
effrayés j'ai jamais eu le sentiment
besoin d'en prendre
jamais jamais jamais non plus parce que
moi je bois pas vous le savez je ne fume
pas même un regard je vois un voilà ça
doit être ça que l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé parce que
j'étais marquée par un ami d'enfance qui
malheureusement a eu des soucis quand
j'étais très jeune et qu'il y avait à
peu près le même âge que moi et j'ai vu
son désarroi ça l'a conduit dans des
circonstances très compliqué j'ai vu le
désarroi de ses parents et moi ça m'a
vacciné avis en revanche oui bien sûr
que j'ai croisé des gens dans le milieu
du show business qui se trouvaient dont
on le savait jamais devant moi parce que
on a le sentiment que d'une pudeur à la
norme de la poudre ou dans des trucs
excepté qu ici et que ça et qu'on le
voit dans toutes les loges etc
c'est toujours ce très caché en tout cas
ça m'a toujours été caché je n'ai jamais
vu moi j'ai toujours eu peur que gilles
verdez se drogue très cher vous savez
moi ça m'est arrivé mais n'ont été ils
vont vous étiez quoi c'était quoi
c'était le nom mais moi c'est alors je
vous dis il ya deux lits à 2 profils
doit pas se conduire et à ceux qui sont
au coeur d'une équipe on l'a fait et le
brent qui se passe c'est que je vous
dirais c'est la bce
c'est inadmissible au sommet dans les
attendait sur aucun jeu ne fait aucun
prosélytisme je ne dis pas que c'est
bien je vous dirai comment ça fonctionne
il n'y a pas de gens qui tombent dedans
d'un coup d'accord mais j'en ai dit
voilà je vais faire ça il dira si j'ai
raison je fais la fête
bon le lendemain vous êtes fracasse les
doigts c'est dégueulasse que vous d'être
alliance et duda et donc il vous faut le
samedi pour se remettre et le dimanche 1
et puis vous dites à battant samedi je
suis pas bien je vais je vais à
commencer donc du coup vous êtes publié
le lundi
et puis publié le mardi depuis et après
nous dit qu'il ya offert des émissions
est ce que ça vous est arrivé de dire
voilà je suis pas bien jamais jamais sûr
faut surtout pas le faire
jamais jamais de la vie jamais de la vie
il ya des animateurs ya jean luc delarue
par exemple mais jean-luc que je
laissais un peu il
il a toujours reconnu qu'il utilisait la
fête que le club vendredi puis après il
a fait la fête le jeudi et le vendredi
après le jeudi le vendredi et samedi et
dimanche
et forcément le mardi il dit qu'elle est
mal au dos pour aller à l'émission mais
c'est pas que lui c'est le cycle c'est
malheureusement chic et un grain de
sable celui qu'on est moins bien et moi
j'étais vieux sam avait été protégé de
saoro non mais j'aurais pu tomber
encore comme d'autres ça n'a pas été le
cas voilà très bien mais je suis moi je
ne sortais pas j'allais pas en boîte je
n'ai pas si j'étais chez moi que des
copains donc c'est déjà le cas de vos
protège quand même voilà sûr et il y un
des animateurs qui m'a dit l'animateur
un jour qui m'a dit on peut pas faire
une grande carrière
sinon c'est impossible c'est bon c'est
un résumé c'est impossible ayez ou
d'autres actuelle et c'est vrai que jean
lui et vous étiez son dealer ouais j'ai
un luke donald et c'est vrai que c'est
qui ça a été de l'un des exemples les
plus connus
à la télévision il en est bien décédé
vous étiez sur deezer vous dites dont
jean luc delarue cause qu'est ce que
c'est lui qui vous a sollicité
ah oui mais aussi rue bien sûr mais
c'était comment dire elle c'était le
bouche à oreille toi moi j'allais aux
bains douches
est ce qu'il a dit là c'est très
pertinent c'est tout à fait ça on se
prendre dans un cercle vicieux
on est fatigué le lendemain on doit
aller au boulot alors on reprendre la
coque est bien comme ça et ça s'arrête
pas et ce que dit ophélie winter on en
prend voulu récompenser pas vrai que
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui je sais pas
mais je veux dire moi je parle des
années 80 pratiquement toi ça a changé
un parce que ça s'est popularisé c'est
ce que moi c'était les années 80 c'est
avec ces tirs c'est la grande découverte
c'était comment dirais-je y avait des
dés c'est comme si on avait découvert
l'amérique tout le monde devant
l'américain non mais ça dépend
gérard vous regrettez tout ça ou pas
fanon maintenant on va voir grimpe à 30
ans mais bon blé parce que ça coûtait la
vie quand même
jean luc delarue ça doit coûter la vie
ouais mais lui l'a bien cherché aussi il
faut dire que lui il apprenait en
sarbacane et moi j'ai dit et fais pas le
con qui va de choper d'ailleurs comme
bernard tapie on ne va pas chercher loin
puisque c'est pareil les cancers de les
autres bernard tapie comment pourrais
pas dire ça sur berlin je l'aï dit dans
mon bouquin je sais mais je sais dans
bernard aujourd'hui malade je vois
simplement que quand on se chope un
cancer de l'oesophage
on ne sait pas
de l'estomac et des intestins saviola et
la réalité il ya plein de gens qui n'ont
jamais rien fait on trouve
malheureusement conséquences éthiques
oui oui on entrait franchement pour
bernard tapie je vous reprends parce que
ce que vous avez dit dans votre livre
c'est vrai que j'ai dit dans mon goût et
mais même ça fait procès lui il dit que
son cancer est largement due au stress
qu'on lui a infligé par les process arts
le fait de se faire des noeuds à
l'estomac sarah aurait déclenché ça donc
je voudrais dire à la bosnie dans ce
métier où la vie bien sûr qu'ils
laissent donc mais il ya beaucoup de
stress en prenant de la coke aussi il
faut pas oublier oui en tout cas de la
rue pour rester sur de la rue je lui dis
mais la coke c'est fait pour sidi
feeling c'est vrai mais j'ai les fosses
nasales arrachés ah oui normal j'ai dit
si tu vas te coucher avec tu prends des
kits de grammes de bourdeilles tu vas te
coucher la nuit sans te laver le truc
avec une solution saline forcément le
lendemain ça te ronge la cocaïne s'est
fait même effet avec de l'acide
chlorhydrique la cauquenne faut le
savoir et de la chaux à la base donc si
les produits mais bien sûr c'est des
produits qui sont pour vous pourquoi en
fait ça fait quoi je sais ça fait quoi
c'est signé les choses le hamas alors
provoqué quoi jean luc delahaye santé
dans un sens soir quand je me confiance
en soi l'euphorie à huy aux favoris a
évidemment évidemment il y en a plein
comme ça qu'ils peuvent pas le boulot
sans avoir même des braqueurs moi j'ai
connu les plus grands braqueurs de paris
je dis pas de france mais de paris et
ces mecs-là et venez me voir il faut 50
grammes pour aller braquer j allais
passant comme grave comment vous avez
décidé de tout balancer à il y en a
certains c'est par vengeance comme awa
chirac ou des rendez vous parlez de
jacques chirac jacques chirac ancien
président doit ni la cocaïne pont il
était saoul mais l'une à la louche
incroyable avec dassault moi j'étais
j'ai fait un seul coup elle arrive
procès pour celui dont j'ai aucun procès
depuis deux ans et demi que je suis là
j'ai eu aucun procès parce que je dis là
c'est extrêmement grave pour les
familles mine de rien qui nous regardent
la vérité vous demandez-vous lui
demander de venir et d'acquis d'or de
l'histoire de trous vous dites je viens
et dit tout et dès qu'ils sortent de
trois bébés et tout le monde sait pas où
il est normal et il dit ce qu'il a vu
dray si vous n'y a rien de la rumeur on
est passé à autre chose qu il ya eu il
ya eu la cocaïne abandonné pardonnez moi
ou c'est commencer une espèce de cocaïne
mondaine très précisément au début des
années 90 notamment à calage des années
pas encore mais aussi le problème des
médicaments mais aussi pour tenir assez
bien c'est pas qu'un problème de cocaïne
jamais et quand on dit il ya certains
danton pas et dont on n'apprenait pas
dans les années l eau mais la vraie
jacques chirac c'est vrai que c'est
hallucinant girard ouais bah ouais c'est
vrai mais si vous étiez son fournisseur
mais j'étais son fournisseur ment jamais
jamais deux lieutenants
1 c'était et limal qu'un israélien qui
avait fait salle et où est son sens mon
cousin était chauffeur de chirac et donc
il venait me prendre 100 grammes par
semaine
pour sûr être 100 grammes par semaine
oui mais c'est la cli tous à toutes les
crises et c'est fou oui non moi ça m'a
plu alors rejoignez un truc aussi j'ai
lu dans votre livre vous avez notamment
déclaré avoir été le fournisseur de
johnny hallyday je suis fan absolu de
johnny c'est issam a délivré tout je dis
que parce que quand on juge
d'instruction m'a dit vous ouvriez vous
excuser auprès des gens que vous avez
empoisonné gip avant même j'ai pas
compris
un midi oui vous avez compris je dis bah
écoutez moi au contraire on devrait me
donner l'ordre du mérite en france ah
oui bah oui parce que grâce à moi de
jeunes à l'idée tenait dans ses portes
dans ses concerts il ces deux départs
mais qui qui a fait comme johnny on ne
pouvait pas les jeunes qui nous
regardent et mes bijoux là pendant le
sujet sur ophélie winter vous me disiez
heureusement j'en suis sorti ah oui qui
moi oui mais oui heureusement bien sûr
j'ai trente années c'est un poison
ça pourrait sauver mais non je veux pas
me faire l'apologie ses 75 ans et je
suis passé
n'est pas la moindre chance je n'ai
jamais dormi une nuit dans un hôpital ça
nous va oui mais bon je prends l'exemple
jean luc delarue que musa quitte à 48
ans lui mais lis pas pareil d'abord il
buvait beaucoup
ben oui mal venue alors pour effacer les
effets de l'alcool chez lacoste drogue
c'est valérie bénaïm on ne peut pas dire
gérard fauré que la drogue c'est pas
dangereux peut pas dire que la drogue
c'est pas méchant c'est pas comme un
charme parce qu'on a pris de la drogue
vous avez une chance insolente sahara et
vous attend et vous êtes en bonne santé
et tant mieux pour vous mais on peut pas
dire aujourd'hui à une heure de grande
écoute à la télévision 2016 c'est
formidable la drogue et grâce à moi non
plus tard il a dit johnny péter le feu
c'est grâce à mon devrait s'en va dire
ça je peux apporter une précision par
rapport à johnny oui je dis quand même
que j'ai très bien connu pendant les 4 5
mois avant une représentation il
touchait pas un goût une goutte d'alcool
et il faisait de la gym tous les ans
c'est ça qu'ils le devraient et regarder
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai oui
oui ce qui m'énerve c'est que notamment
dans l'extrait ophélie winter elle fait
passer simple pour un truc cool
socialement c'est cool je suis un arbre
sur le défense prend de la coke à plein
de gens qui n'a remporté que quoi qu'ils
pensent aussi que les artistes c'est
plus stimulant intellectuellement avec
de la coke alors que c'est de la merde
et que tous les gens qui sont succès
soul dans ces métiers là dans la musique
etc etc sont des gens que je travaille
beaucoup et que ça vous empêche
précisément de travail et donc il faut
dire aux gens que c'est vrai qu'on fait
avec ça vous rend les gens si moi je
sais chérie ça vous empêche notre rythme
à ses sabots des compagnies voient la
pause et déconcentrés impossible girard
gamme avec des mecs qui kills qui voilà
qui qui qui arriva surtout je vous
dirais rose-croix à ce qu'on dit c'est
pas un excitant ça vous rend totalement
abruti ou d'un moment c'est vrai mais
non mais vous des travaux outil complet
du web j'ai moi j'ai croisé des gens
élus c'est qu'en cdd les cdi et légumes
c'est assez horrible et une bourse
comporte qu'on va très vite mais en fait
on est on est nul
complet gérard il faut quand même dire
que vous avez vendu de la drogue à des
célébrités vous avez été condamné
donc revenons à la base c'est illégal
quand même il faut dire ça tu pouvais
pas faire l'apologie de la drogue joue
dix ans les six usines avaient dit que
certains artistes étaient transcender
dans leurs performances ou parce qu'ils
prenaient de la drogue et que les vrais
vrillé avoir l'ordre du mérite là
honnêtement rotimi amaechi oui là vous
exagérez mais je sais qu'il faut le dire
mais c'était un peu pour renvoyer la
balle à magis d'instruction qui vraiment
abusé quoi c'est tous mes biens a
détruit jour la drogue ça détruit les
sens aller maintient sous dépendance
nature sais mais bon ce qui est bien
c'est que les deux les deux pieds qui en
parlent qu'ils connaissent en fait ils
te disent que ça te rend abrutis les que
ça ne sert strictement à rien donc ça
c'est vache qui rit et on salue le
courage de benjamin qui en parle c'est
très fort d'en parler parce que c'est
vrai que dans le showbiz personne
personne va te dire qu'il en prend ils
disent tous j'en prends pas on sait on
sait qu'ils en prennent et te dise où
j'en prends parents gerry dit mais je
reviens le v10 rien à ce cas ce qu'a dit
benjamin au début je pense qu'il ya des
avocats aussi quand prenne il ya des
chefs d'entreprises comprennent cela
dépend du milieu social où tu n es ça
dépend dans quelle soirée tu te
retrouves dans la haute finance à rungis
parfois quand il se lève à 3h du matin
tu pourras pas beaucoup de cocaïne à
rungis t'as pas beaucoup de cocaïne chez
les chauffeurs livreurs chez les
bouchers tu en as plus dans les soirées
mondaines dans la puce dans les soirées
où les mecs qui vont en boîte de nuit où
c'est facile d'en avoir et n'oublie pas
surtout que la cocaïne faut la paix vous
en avoir de l'argent pour la durée de la
vérité il avait là vous ben oui mais
pour moi cette scène
ben oui et j'en lui
cette soirée pink à l'honneur qu'à
envoyer des filets les saladiers mais ça
ne m'a jamais jamais tenté j'ai une
indifférence non je n'ai pas besoin tu
as déjà s'est attaqué aux mondiaux oui
bon on en a déjà proposé après
contrairement aux clichés qu'ils ont
essayé
jamais je n'ai jamais pris de cocaïne
boit pas d'alcool jamais j'avais même
peut même pas rejoint cdh a peur c'est
ça ouais non mais si oui j'ai peur tu
devrais peut-être d'être accro peut-être
je sais pas mais j'en ai jamais rien en
revanche contrairement aux clichés qui y
est j'ai jamais vu de genre notamment
télé en prendre dans le cadre du travail
c'est parfois les gens et des genres
défonce pour faire la fête ce qui est
complètement nul et puis problème c'est
que ça vous coupe socialement des gens
ça quand vous êtes avec des gens qui
prennent de la coke que la coke sort en
soirée ça devient de l'obsession de tout
le monde et vous ne pouvez plus parler
que ces gens là donc c'est simple il ya
pas de succès story avec la avec l'ado
moi j'en ai vu beaucoup parce que dans
la mode à l'époque la mode c'est un
coupe faim et donc forcément les chiens
ont consommé beaucoup et moi j'ai vu
beaucoup de chez soi faire des
tentatives de suicide soit tombé en
dépression soit terminée en hôpital
psychiatrique
donc il faut dire monsieur globalement
manolas toujours très très très mal le
vrai et moi j'aime bien ce qu'elle dit
ophélie à l'époque moi je sors beaucoup
avec elle
aubin au palace à tous a effectivement
vous aurez dès qu'on fait vous sortirez
qu'on fait du web
on était même si on était vraiment il
avait déjà touché à sa non j'ai jamais
toucher à ça parce que j'ai vu des gens
cliniquement ou mourir et disparaît elle
s'arrêter ça m'a fait super peur
effectivement j'ai pas voulu toucher à
ça mais moi je trouve que malgré tout
elle assez sincère alors oui c'est un
peu une formule de télé dire ouais mais
tout le monde touché mais à cette époque
aubin tout le monde touche et à la corée
c'était dur à aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je trouves tu vas me dire si
je me trompe je vais maintenant me voilà
moi je suis pas du tout dans ce délire
tu n'aurais su d'ailleurs tu le sais moi
je suis pas du tout dans ce délire ni si
la plupart des gens pareils presse
venait tu vois pas mais j'ai
l'impression que c'était plus une mode
de l'époque en fait cet élément est à
dire que vraiment les animateurs sont un
peu restés dans leur délire dans le truc
c'était certaines parties du monde à
bord c'est une mode c'est vrai ce que tu
dis
dans les années 80 c'est sûr aujourd'hui
ça c'est vachement populariser le mec
dans le drame vécu des choses qu'ils
prennent c'est de la merde c'est pour ça
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui tombent
malades
mais ce que vient de dire madame
quelques pas il ya des gens qui se
suicident c'est vrai se révéler bien dit
dans un égout qui ont même dans les deux
j'ai dit
la coke est on en use mais n'abuse pas
déjà du moment où on a le on a le nez
dans l'ambassade et descendez plein
d'emphase ne savent plus c'est donc en
fait c'est un piège à vis deuxièmement
j'ai dit que la cocaïne augmente les
états l'état d'esprit du moment je sais
pas s'il est d'accord avec moi mais si
on est de bonne humeur
on peut preuve je ne peux pas dire un
peu on prend de la cocaïne
on sent encore mieux d'accord de
meilleure humeur
mais si on est de mauvaise humeur on
peut aller jusqu'au suicide à ces
intervenants
c'est vrai mais droit dans le milieu de
la musique toi ce que ce que tu as déjà
vu ba de la cocaïne en vrai nom mais
après tout ce qui est joint et tous
n'ont rien à y en a pas mal
après ça c'est beaucoup dans les studios
c'est ce qu'on voit énorme bail en a qui
disent que genre c'est pour faire ça
leur permet de décrire décrire leurs
textes etc
après les seules fois où j'ai vu des
personnes en consommer c'était plus à
l'étranger déjà beaucoup moins en france
info qu'il restait plus les patrons de
boîtes les clubs quand on est en show
etc
c'est plus ça mais c'est vrai qu'en
france j'ai jamais vu un chat a jamais
touche à sa fin non je n'ai pas peur je
suis très fier mardi très cools et pas
besoin de d'être excités et tout ça tu
vois non mais ça mais je trouve ça cool
que ce soit moi je préfère que ce soit
un tabou du voici le taux pour lui la
risée et ronda au mode fun ophélie elle
l'a dit c'est cool mais après je vois
pas trop l'intérêt surtout pas mal
d'enfants on regarde ça je préfère que
ça reste comme ça vous faut vous dire
vous êtes des exemples
et c'est vrai que là oui ça c'est hyper
important aussi toi au jury rien que
pour ça déjà suite la main par exemple
de temps en temps je vais fumer une
chicha ou un truc comme ça par exemple
tu vois et je vais pas je vais pas
forcément le snap et je vais pas le
montrer parce que je sais que justement
il ya pas mal de jeunes qui me regarde
tu vois donc je vais je vais faire
attention et c'est vrai que on essaye
tous en tout cas dans le milieu urbain
parce que je le connais donc je peux me
permettre de prôner ce milieu là je sais
qu'on est tous assez protecteur quand
même avec nos rêves nos abonnés tu vas
donc
donc gérard aujourd'hui tu m'as dit tout
à l'heure tu m'as dit on a écrit son
livre aussi pour te venger de certaines
personnes
chirac en particulier pourquoi dimanche
il m'avait donné 2 sec et april a fait
opposition
onze militaires
il à l'échec c'est pas pour la coque ce
débat gamme en joue avec lui au racing
club de france à pacy way et à epernay
des paris de backgammon ils perdent ils
perdaient mais il paye pas et puis après
j'ai la bonne opposition
c'est incroyable ça il me la payer 15000
francs bon à l'époque c'est quand même
sinon alors un jour il me fit une
commande 100 g comme d'habitude pour
aller chez dassault donc je vais chez
dassault mais je prends 50 grammes et je
m'élance avec 50 g de laxatifs c'est un
coming laxatifs déjà la coke c'est un
laxatif et par elle même c'est un faux
nez elle accepte déjà investi que je me
suis mis au barbecue là bas avec un
marocain qui l'épient j'attendais barbe
de cinq dix minutes ça sortait de
partout
smoking c'était pour et dans tous les
sens dès qu'il trouve un buisson il
s'arrêter ce vide est assez dur parce
que je vous avais dit avec benjamin
castaldi c'est que vers midi vraiment de
tomber pas là c'est la vie ça va vous
rendre à briser je voulais de ils ont
vraiment c'est dangereux c'est vraiment
c'est de la merde on va pas c'est bien
qu'il ait dit aussi c'est important
qu'ils le disent et merci gérard fauré
l'éducation d'un voyou dealer du tout
paris des choses cette sortie de tout ça
maintenant
en 2008 75
elle s'accroît par la sangle et vous
gagnez votre vie parce qu'il ya pas de
retraite du coup il fait dès dimanche il
a récupéré il fait des livres en a été
le prince japon qu'on a mis un peu de
teams de quotas
c'est passé 18 années de plaisant pour
un 10 86 m plusieurs poire pour la soif
quand même deux côtés et puis j'ai fait
un bel héritage de mourir mon père qui
m'a payé ses factures en émission va
digérer
oui alors et puis mes bouquins me
rapporte gros si la soul dire aussi raté
mon père il veut réagir oui ordinaire s
qui soit à l'antenne là qu'est ce qui se
passe chaque chili de la schizophrénie
la puissance absolument
ça facilite la schizophrénie et
l'impuissance est surtout l'un des
officiers c'est pour ça qu'il arrêtait
la raison voilà bah c'est important
qu'on ait un avis médical
[Applaudissements]